네 아 저는 김윤수 아고 합니다 제
인터뷰는 한 번도 한 적이 없어
가지고 좀 낯설긴 하는데 어 빌사남
TV 운영하고 있고 주식회사 빌사남
2016년에 창업해서 지금 9년째
열심히 운영하고
[음악]
있습니다 블로그 닉네임이 빌딩
거래하는 청년이었고 2014년도
있는데 거래를 사랑으로 바꾸고 청년을
남자로 바꿔서 빌딩과 사랑에 빠진
남자 블로그를 2014년도에 운영하고
있다가 사람들이 이제 줄여서 빌사남
님 빌사남 님 하면서 회사가 빌사남이
됐고 지금은 주식 회사 bsn
바꿨습니다 해외 진출도 생각하고 있기
때문에네 가정 형편이 좋지 않아서
사회에 좀 빨리 나왔어요 그 중학교
1학년 때 처음 사회를 나왔고 주유소
아르바이트를 했는데 5년 정도
일어났어요 알바생으로 가가지고네
그래서 5년 정도 일하면서 그
주유소가 어떻게 흘러가는지를 그때
봤었고 그리고 어떻게 보면 주유소가
서비서 이잖아요 그래서 손님분들 오면
인사도 잘하고 그리고 이게 대응하는
방법이라든지 지금 와서 도움이 되게
많이 되는 거 같아요 주유소에서
배우면서 주유소 사장님이 부동산
투자에 되게 관심 많으셨거든요 그래서
항상 저한테 부동산 투자 얘기를 해
주셨는데 그거를 계기로 부동산에
관심을 갖게 됐고 실제로 거기 저희
집 살던 곳이 개발이 되면서 이웃
주민분들이 보상받는 걸 옆에서 봤어요
근데 우리 집은 이제 새 살고 있다
보니까 쫓겨나서 아 내가 이제
부동산을 해야겠구나라고 생각을 마음을
먹고 그때 고등학 학생 때 다행히
이제 딱 그 미성년자 제한이 딱
풀리는 시기에 자격증을 도전을 해
가지고 그때 어린 나이에 취득하게
됐습니다네 그래서 약간 자랑을 하자면
전국에 딱 명 붙었어요
10대가 근데 중개사 취득 관련해서도
처음에 이제 학교 선생님한테 나 공인
중개사 취득할 거라고 하니까 무시를
많이 했어요 그래서 앞에 나오라 그런
다음에 친구들 다 있는 자리에서 정말
망신을 줬어요 얘 자격증 절대 못
할거다 너무 제가 진짜 보여
주겠다라고 생각을 하고 고 학원 끊은
다음에 진짜 주구장창 공부를 했습니다
자격증 따자마자 그 선생님 보여
드리러 갔어요 그 선생님이 정말 깜짝
놀라면서 네가 정말 취득할지 몰랐다
그걸 계기로 아 이게 하면
되는구나라는 좀 많이 느끼게 됐어요
그래서 그게 어떻게 보면 지금 빌사남
아지 이어지는 거 같습니다 아 남들이
뭐라하든 무시하던 일단 내 신념대로
꾸준히 하다 보면 무조건 대는 구다
느끼게 된게 어떻게 보면 공인중개사
자격증부터 시작을 했던 거 같습니다
어 그래서 첫 계약이 되게 오래
걸렸어요 그래서 한 10개월 정도
소유가 됐었고 근데 그때 당시에 저희
집안 사정이 되게 안 좋았거든요 뭐
어머님도 뭐 병원치료 받고 있고 그다
아버지도 그때 당시 암에 걸리셔서
수술비도 없었고 사실 영업직이 월
급여하던 이런게 마땅히 없거든요
그래서 계약을 못 쓰면 사실 돈을 못
버는 구조여서 그때 그 해가 제일 좀
힘들었던 거 같아요 아침 5시에
나가서 밤 11시까지 출퇴근을 하고
주말에도 맨날 나와가지고 이랬는데
그렇게 했는데도 계약이 안 나왔어요
10개월 동안 처음에는 되게 좀
슬럼프도 오고 그랬는데 잘될 때
모습을 좀 상상을 했거든요 그리고
제가 10개월 뒤에 이제 첫 계약이
나왔던게 뭐 전화만 하고 했던 분인데
만나서 얘기를 하니까 협상이 되게 잘
된 거예요 그러면서 이제 계약이
나오게 됐습니다 그 고객분 같은
경우에는 건물을 안 보고 샀어요 제말
믿고 그래서 그걸 보면서 느낀게 아
내가 아무리 뭐 좋은 물건 아니면
좋은 상품을 판다 하더라도 신뢰가
없으면 팔 수 없겠구나 신뢰가 있으면
정말 없는 물건도 팔 수 있겠구나
이렇게 생각할 정도로 신뢰에 대한
생각을 좀 많이 하게 됐습니다 그
뒤로 이제 계속 계약이 나온 거예요
어
꾸준히 저 하고 싶은 대로 해 보고
싶었어요 그서 기존에는 원래 아무래도
소속돼 있다 보니까 할 수 있는 일이
좀 제한이 좀 있었는데 제가 아직도
젊고 워낙 이제 하고 싶은게 많아서
그냥 내가 하고 싶은 데로 해봐야겠다
라고 해서 이제 창업을 결심하게 됐고
처음에는 월세 70만 원짜리 주택에서
시작했어요 제 책상 보시면 깜짝
놀라실 건데 그냥 직원 한 명이랑
같이 창업을 했습니다 이제 먹고
자면서 그래서 그때 이제 처음
개발하게 된게 어 앱을
개발했었는데 그때부터 이제 또
중개업을 하게 되는데 중학교 때 졸업
장에 이런 거 쓰잖아요 밑에 거기
보면은 20년 후에 CEO 되겠다라고
이렇게 써 놨더라고요 저는 어렸을
때부터 되게 사업에 관심 많았고 회사
다니면서도 계속 창업 생각을 했던 거
같아요 심지어는 면접 볼 때 5년
안에 회사 대표가 되겠다고
했었어요 어 전의 회사 면접 볼 때
그래서 그 정도로 사업에 대한 어
그런 생각들이 되게 많았던 거
같습니다네 사실 이게 다 영업이
그래서 사람의 마음을 사는게 제일
중요하다라고 생각을 해서 일단은
영업을 잘하려고 노력을 많이 했던 거
같아요 대부분 영업하는 사람들 중에
가장 많이 실수하는게 말을 잘해야지
영업을 잘한다고 생각을 하는데
실제로는 저는 고객의 이야기를 잘
들어 줬습니다 예를 들어서 60분을
만나면 한 50분 정도를 다른
얘기예요 사실 고객 얘기 계속 들어
줘요네 어떻게 성공하게 되셨어요 뭐
자녀분들은 뭐 하세요 어 사님 이거는
뭐예요 뭐 계속 그냥 질문만 해요
그리고 나머지 10분을 일 얘기합니다
근데 대부분 다 이제 영업 처음하시는
분들은 다짜고짜 만나서 이제 영업
얘기만 해요 일단 사람의 마음 마음을
안
열었거든요데 안 연 상태에서 아무리
영업해도 영업이 되지 않습니다 그래서
대부분 다 만나면이 팔장 끼고 있어요
어떻게 하면 저 팔장을 빨리 풀 수
있을까를 좀 고민을 해야 됩니다
그래서 계속 사적인 얘기하고 얘기
계속 들어주고 우리가 사실 되게 힘든
일 있으면 친구가 내 이야기 들어
주기만 해도 기분이 되게 풀리잖아요
그 고객분 얘기도 계속 들어주다
보면은 마음을 열게 돼 있어요 그래서
그게 되게 좀 영업에 있어서 되게
핵심
포인트였지만 그렇게 생각을 합니다
그리고 이게 제가 술을 안 먹잖아요
대부분의 사람들은 이제 영업할 때
술을 먹어야지 이제 영업을 잘한다라고
생각하는데 돈이 크게 들어가는 일은
확실한 사람이랑 하게 돼 있습니다 어
우리가 연애하는 사람이랑 결혼하는
사람이 다르듯이 고객도 내가 막 술
먹고 친했던 사람이 있는 방면에
실제로 계약하는 사람은 확실한
사람하고 하게 돼 있습니다 그래서
이거는 되게 많은 분들이 좀
오해하시는 거 같아요 그래서 저는
술을 안 먹고 지금까지 영업을 잘해
왔습니다네 맨날 1등으로 나왔어요 뭐
그때도 그렇고 지금도 그렇고 오늘도
저도 6시에 나왔는데 그 아침 시간이
되게 소중하거든요 그래서 그때 좀
많이 이제 준비를 했다가 이제 업무
시간대 이제 다 시간마다 촘촘하게
썼던 거 같아요 그래서 제가 그때
집이 광명이 있는데 강남에서 광명까지
거리가 그래도 좀 되긴 하거든요 그
이동 시간에도 뭘 했던 거 같아 책을
보거나 뭐 일하거나 그랬던 거
같습니다
지금 회사 내에 이렇게 좀 빌드업
하면은 잘 될 거 같은 분들이 좀
있거든요 그래서 그런 분들을 좀 더
키울 생각이고 좀 중개사들이 위상을
되게 높이고 싶어요 그니까 요즘에
워낙 SNS 발달되면서 이제 유사
중개인들이 되게 많아졌는데 그걸로
인해서 중개사들이 되게 좀 설 곳이
좀 많이 없어졌거든요 무시도 많이
당하고 일은 일대로 하는데 어 돈은
못 벌고네 그런게 너무 많아서 이런
중개사들이 위상을 좀 많이 높이려고
노력을 많이 할 겁니다 그리고 저는
일단 부동산과 관련된 일은 다 할
거고요 그다음에 해외 진출도 생각을
하고 있고 지금 하고 싶은게 사실
엄청 많거든 제 지금 자리에 보면
열댓개 정도 있어요 지금 신규를 하고
싶은게 그래서 아마 좀 차곡차곡
진행할 예정입니다 한창 열심히 해야
될 시기예요 지금 30대 이제 거의
중반인데 어 아직 한창 해야 될
시기입니다 그래서 매일 뭐해 먹고
살지네 어떤 사업을 할지 매일
고민하고 있습니다 근데 이거의 전제는
본업은 잘해야 됩니다 그래서 본진은
잘 지키고 본업이 된 상태에서 해야지
본업을 안 하고 다른 사업만 하면 다
같이
망하거나 본업을 열심히 한 다음에
하겠다네 이렇게 생각을 하시면 될 거
같습니다 새로운 도전도 많이 할
생각이고 여러분들 많이 좀 기대해
주시고 앞으로 영상 열심히 찍을테니까
잘 지켜봐 주시기 바랍니다 오늘 영상
여기까지 하겠습니다 감사합니다
[음악]